hi guys in this video I'm going to show
you how to get rid of hip pain now you
can do this on yourself or your going to
you might need some help to have someone
do it on you so let me show you how to
fix hip pain alright guys I'm going to
show you how to get rid of hip pain so
let's pretend that she has right-sided
hip pain now the pelvis is right from
here down to here and the hip is right
in the center so if she has hip pain on
the right side we're going to press on
the opposite side the left side now what
you're going to do is you're going to do
three things you're going to press on
the opposite mirror image side and just
massage this now if you were going to do
it you could take a tennis ball or a
racket ball and lay it on this side do
not press on the side that hurts work on
the opposite side and this is something
they don't tell you or teach you in
school but it works like magic so what
we want to do is want to press on that
hip and really stimulate it now the
opposite mirror image side the where the
pain is is going to be very tender so go
light and you'll be surprised how tender
this is but the way we know we got the
exact opposite spot is the tenderness so
we're trying to find the epicenter of
where the most tenderness is and we're
going to work that out and you know just
massage it for like two minutes okay
that's step one now step two is we're
going to go we work on the muscle that's
attached to the hip so you got hip as
hip joint as a joint and it's a bone
connected with another bone but there's
a lot of muscle attachments with that so
what we want to do if she hurts over
here we want to work on the muscle
that's above the hip okay
and it's like right up in here and it's
like right in there and there's going to
be a little muscle above that hip that
you're going to just work out it'll be
very tight and very sore okay let's step
to work on that muscle massage it again
you could you could take foam roller and
work on that area you can strip all the
way down here as well which is not a bad
idea to work on this thigh but then what
we want to do
is the hip comes up right here we want
to work on the inside of the abdomen and
massage this point on the opposite side
with a hip pain is why because on this
side there's a muscle that is on the
inside of your spine that attaches to
this leg right here and it's called the
iliopsoas muscle and what you're going
to do is going to press down in there
and it's going to be really tender so
you want to gently work out all the soft
tissue on this side all the way down to
here okay so we're working on the
opposite side of the hip the muscle just
above and the muscle right through and
here okay so those are the three steps
to get rid of hip pain now if this
doesn't work then we know that the pain
is referred from usually if it's a
female the ovary the ovary if there's a
cyst on it will refer pain on that side
of the hip or the hip bone in the back
is called the sacroiliac joint so in
that case what you want to do is give
the person some seek help because seek
help
gets rid of cysts faster than anything I
know so because it's missing iodine
iodine reduces estrogen and that's where
it's coming from it's estrogen dominance
so again these are just there's
different causes of hip pain and it also
could be an injury as well but go ahead
and apply this technique and make your
comments below